hey what's up guys I'm Kip Moore and
you're watching certified country with
so Keisha lacy
[Music]
hey guys I'm sobytia' lighting here with
Kip Moore welcome to paradise I know
it's right this is this is all right
right I wish I could do all my own herbs
here on though right we're here in
Jamaica tell us what we're doing here
you're performing tonight yeah
I'm it's kind of story behind the songs
of this new record coming out September
8th
you know it's also benefiting the
Sandals foundation so it's a cool thing
and I'm gonna kind of play some new
songs from a slow heart record and talk
about you know the process of making
them
if this might work for you or is this
play this is chill play I've been making
this record for the whole past year so
around touring and making the record
it's been a pretty strenuous year as far
as that goes
times like these are you know I get to
eat rum sugar cane 6:00 and chill out so
it this is this is a good time we have a
rapid-fire round of questions coming
country quickly I have changed them now
to Paradise edition tropical drink of
choice I'm gonna say a run runner now I
don't I don't lead drink tropical drinks
I'm more of like a toccata guy but this
is pretty amazing what is your go-to SPF
number 15 15 that's a good one
you don't burn but you still get some
colored a beach party boombox jam
anything with Bob Marley and I'm good to
go now if you have 24 hours to spend
would you rather go sightseeing or relax
on the beach add with a jump it fits his
car let him take me right out because he
seems like he knows what's up this is
this is the famous fits right if she was
gonna take me into the town where would
you take me straight in the heart of
Jamaica make you know so much I'm makin
cultures do you know exactly does have
some more good American food cuisine
yeah someone let me come up an
experiment to make a call at JB all
right last one what is the best vacation
you've ever been on the most profound
and powerful vacation I've been on has
been a Iceland
now I want to show you something I
brought a little something the new album
yeah that's what matters yes hold it
that'll change your life how does it
feel having that in your hands this is
the first hard copy I've seen really
yeah I feel good about this yeah is this
gonna be a big one for you I think so I
just I think this is a special record
talking
named slow heart I actually had a band
member give me that name a long time ago
he said you're a slow heart he says it
takes you a while to like you observe
stuff you don't wear your heart on your
sleeve and you you you absorb everything
before you actually show your cards and
your colors in your heart he said your
slow heart the way this record was made
it was such a long organic fashion where
it just felt like it was time to be
called so hard what's your favorite song
on the album I would say I would say a
bittersweet company and your song blonde
is getting a ton of buzz yeah that's I
think that's a special song I think it's
so fitting for the times that we're in
right now you know I was I was just
trying to touch on the whole social
media Instagram world we live in you
know so I think that that song is gonna
resonate with a lot of people well there
is one blondes here that we love and her
name is Lauren Elena tell me about your
relationship with Lauren Lauren I've
known her for a long time and I truly
love that chick she's just an amazing
light I mean it she she's she's always
having a good time she's got a really
good spirit about it we've written
together I've just seen her grow
throughout the years and I'm super
stoked forth well Cheers
I know this is this is this is all right
okay so we have switched locations we
are now here at the spa with who's
Lauren Alaina at sandal south coast so
you are also here with your love your
boy and you know this is like a wedding
honeymoon Dustin no we've been watching
everybody get married I like literally
watch the wedding happens yeah it was
beautiful I loved it what is like your
dream wedding scenario I probably want
to get married in a church yeah I'm done
traditional about that I really love but
I don't know like put me on this I'm not
having to think about it yet I want to
talk about what a huge year you've had
I think road less traveled really been a
game changer for you hitting the
recognition that you so well deserved
thank you it's nuts for me to even like
try to put it into words it's crazy
because I've been trying to make this
happen the whole life and it's really
crazy when you feel that moment
all the hard work kind of paying off
I'll never forget when I got the phone
called it road less traveled was not
gonna go higher on the charts because it
couldn't possibly go higher on the chart
[Music]
[Music]
when that song is so important to my
story and my message as an artist it's
so meaningful to me as a person that
that's the one that kind of set me up
for all of it you're following it up
with something also super meaningful
doing fine I love the message of that
song Oh biographical is that for you
it's pretty identical to my story it's
about my family's divorce and I moved to
Nashville and all of these just big
life-changing events happened my dad's
an alcoholic and he went through rehab
and I talked about that in the song I'm
in this unique position where people
look up to me and people like are always
commenting and they'll say things like
you're so perfect you're here that's in
that and I just wanted to let them know
that I'm actually not I wanted to have a
real connection with people and you can
only connect with people if they really
know you growing up in the spotlight
through Idol and all of that I think
you've always been a role model but I
really feel you leaning into it well I
had to like get to a place where I felt
comfortable with it it really freaked me
out at first because it made me feel
like almost inferior because people were
like wanting to come to me for advice
and I didn't know how to give it I was
16 and I was really lost and I'm eating
disorder and then I kind of sorted
through all of those things and now I'm
able to share how I went through them my
fans make me a better person because I
don't want to be the girl that does
something crazy and gets that reputation
like I'm really trying to set a good
example
Real Talk though is I don't coming back
too soon gosh you know no I'm excited
that it's back I know that like some
people don't when they come on those
shows they don't want to talk about it
after they're off of the show and I'm
like I'm always dealing to talk about it
because I think it's ungrateful not to
talk about where you came from so I'm
even asked to be a part no yes yes no
maybe I have we haven't officially like
I'm not officially going to be a part of
it but I've definitely been in talks
with them now I heard a rumor that your
tour buddy Luke Bryan was being
considered maybe for a judge's chair
have you heard that I have heard that I
don't know it would that's real I will
say I think he would nail that position
because I think that he's very smart and
has been very successful and people will
trust what he has to say I think that
people would be really surprised at how
like
right he would be at that speaking of
idle what is one piece of advice you
would give your younger self today but
tell her a lot because I was pretty lost
I let other people control my feelings
we have to ignore what people say about
us and I would tell her to take more
pictures I wish I had more pictures I
can use that advice I think I could give
you that advice thank you so much whoa
hey Rach whoa girlfriend let's go
wrapping up the day here before the show
James burger man you guys are you just
got here first of all like an hour ago
yeah so tonight you guys are performing
also Lauren Alaina and Kip Moore tell me
about sharing the stage with those guys
it's gonna be a pretty special moment
for us we've had the opportunity to open
up for Kip on a few different festivals
in Canada in that kind of thing and see
his full you know whole van performance
so we're super excited to see and they
stripped down and we got the chance to
see Lauren and Elena at CRS and which
was like mind-blowing she's unbelievable
standing ovations yeah I love that all
right well I'm so excited